it was crazy because i diagnosed myself
mm-hmm
i said to the doctor i go i think i have
a brain tumor like my mom
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sistine and
sophia stallone i like introing you
always do it first i know i know do you
like the switch-up
oh yeah do it now from here on out i
think so i think so we always have this
debate who's better at the intro i still
think i do i think i have the voice for
the intro you know
someone said the other day that i had a
little sharp tone in my voice
and is that true yes really yes
should i speak softer that's a little
sexual yeah it's just why your voice is
deep
and i feel like it's it is
you know what's so weird when we were
young my dad always trained our voice
weird flex he gave us vocal training
lessons almost every single day so we'd
have to talk into a tape recorder and
this is for real for years we did this
talk into a tape recorder and do
um what are those like limericks phrases
what are they called like peter piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers
sally sells shells by the season you
know what i'm talking about and so he'd
make us also read really old poetry into
a tape recorder
so that we would properly pronounce and
he always trained us to make our voice
really really deep yeah because one day
i was talking and he goes it is way too
high pitch for me
so that's uh that's why it's funny
because we have these home videos of us
screaming um in our living room at 6 00
a.m because my dad wanted us to read the
young lambs for sale
screaming it he wouldn't and he'd also
used to put a tissue paper in front of
our face and make us pronounce our peas
and if the tissue paper didn't fly high
enough he'd make a start over and it's
funny because people are probably
listening saying that is torture for a
child but he always said to us i wish i
had parents that helped me with my
speech delay in my sleep because parents
say
you and scarlett had a slight speech
delay yeah so it helped no i went to a
speech therapist to help my speech like
not my father but you know i the one
thing i will benefit from that and i
would say i benefited i would have i'm
more of a loud talker and maybe that's
not the best thing ever all the time but
that's also helped with a lot of these
things we're doing i would say the one
thing that
doing that benefited me was
we can now say that we have the weird
flex of reciting the raven by edgar
allan poe by heart
so we could do that and it's one of
those weird skills that no one ever
actually needs but it's kind of cool
i remember it was at my uh elementary
school and we had a talent show and that
was the thing i did was the raven and my
dad
freaked out he was so happy should we
share what else we did at that school
we must have been the weirdest kids ever
we also signed up for the burping
competition
and guess what your girls won we won we
were the only girls that signed up as
well and we won we well this is the
thing my dad said this is the coolest
thing a girl can do so weeks before we
would train and we drink right he was so
he wanted us to be good at it without
soda and with soda so so
on demand yeah i'm not going to pretty
nasty i'll be honest you know what we
used to do as well
my dad would get on the intercom of our
house that would just microphone speaker
to the entire every single room and he'd
get on
belch hang up the phone and then we'd
respond
and my mom would get so mad i completely
forgot that thank you
i know i get oh god it's like the thing
is it's like our births are not cute now
because they're so good they're
they're loud it sounds like an ogre
screaming so it's like since i'm in this
new relationship sometimes i'm like have
the urge to do i'm like no you're a lady
you're a lady you're like you
will never see me burp or fart in front
of a guy no me neither that does not
exist those bodily functions girls can
do it it's fine for me they don't come
out it doesn't it's because mom put that
in our heads for sure don't do it but i
also agree with her no i will be in a
crippling pain in a ball on my carpet
holding that [ __ ] in until i'm crying
before i let anything slip out that's
like what the dumb side about staying
with a guy is for a week is that you
literally can't do anything and so
you're in physical pain bloated you know
i'm sorry it's just the most awesome
i'll say the elephant in the room you
don't poop no
you don't sorry no
and if you will sucks you make up an
excuse about how you're gonna leave the
room and go across the street to your
little cafe oh yeah or whatever
hopefully if there's a cabin maybe
you'll knock on your neighbor's door
or you just won't but the best trick
that i've learned over the years
always when you go to a hotel a front
desk whatever it may be pick up a set of
matches
after you
after the train leaves the station if
you will light up a match blow it out
cancels the smell guys yeah you're
welcome it does smell like a forest fire
it's
like a fire but it's better than it's
more than the opposite i rather it may
seem like something was burning in the
bathroom
you know
we had an idea for this intro
did not expect to talk about um feces so
let's move on uh
cinco de mayo
la cucaracha
did you celebrate
wait no i was with you yeah you were
with me
why okay cinco de mayo is one of those
holidays that you have such high
expectations like tequila tacos like
we're going to go crazy
never have i will i actually never had
high expectations for cinco de mayo i
think no everyone just uses it as a day
to go hey let's go out and get tequila
right i don't think no but it's like st
patrick's day it's like days that you're
supposed to be drinking and then you
don't
yeah but i know there's a there's
something behind cinco de mayo that
people are like why are you celebrating
it i don't i think they're mad that
americans are using it as a way to just
like get drunk and drink together i
don't blame them yeah there's like
something behind it but i wish we did
something fun except
we did the opposite we just went to bed
at like 7 30. i'll tell you what i did i
ate dinner around 5 30 with me with
sophia
was back in my apartment by 6 30 and i
was like oh [ __ ] now how do i kill the
next four hours what'd you do
i watched four episodes of yellowstone i
thought it'd be a good idea to stretch
um popped both my hips
don't feel good right now it's not like
you're 80 years old i feel like the tin
man yeah so you know the fact that i
still can't touch my toes at 23. it's
pretty bad it's really bad
you haven't made an effort to try though
that is true that is true another thing
that we've been watching a lot is the
playboy mansion reality show that was
back in like the 2000s the girls next
door yeah
because oh that's what it's called i
did not realize that you could stream
the show
it is so nostalgic to watch it because
first of all it's the worst quality
you've ever seen horrible horrible
quality but when we were watching it as
a kid first of all we'd sneak watch it
because
we thought we'd get in trouble and of
course we'd get in trouble for watching
it as little girls but we pretend to go
to bed sophie and i would put it on yeah
and we were just like so fascinated by
these girls
there's obviously some twisty things
behind the scenes that we probably
weren't aware of at the time but when
you're nine years old you don't know the
logistics of what's going on you see
pretty girls and bunny suits and i
idolize these girls so much they had
like these you idolized them oh my god
you don't understand they have these big
boobs in this huge blonde hair
and i was like that is what i want i
wanted it so bad as a little girl to be
a playboy but
you got to understand like i didn't like
my life
i didn't know
what the assignment was as a
nine-year-old i didn't know you had to
sleep with hugh hefner i didn't know all
that all i knew is they were gorgeous
and they got attention from men and i
was like
wow like no one had a crush on me of
course that is funny yeah it was so
fabulous i wanted to do it so badly
that's fair but pedro is my fave kendra
is my favorite too and i'm not just
saying that i'm like she's the funniest
person ever i love it i am obsessed with
that show i will i've been watching it i
think i'm on season two now you are
pretty on it i love it and you're also
on a plane soon to go to oklahoma
to visit our father and mom and three
dogs
i can't say i had a choice entirely in
this decision
mom has been there with dad and the
three dogs and she's a bit miserable
being alone so i was like you know what
take one for the team yeah and plus you
like going on set so our dad is filming
a show in oklahoma which is really cool
and it's
with the guy that's made yellowstone
taylor sheridan sheridan and apparently
it is probably some of his best work mom
said he's acting incredibly well i have
a plan um i have a plan what's your plan
all right
so first part of my plan is i need to
find a horse
that's step one step one step two
i need to ride said horse
in front of taylor sheridan and press
him a thought goes through his brain
thinking huh
she'd be really good in yellowstone
hmm yeah
yeah you're just gonna just walk in
front of him and he's gonna think that
girl looks good on the horse yeah it's
pretty smart you know some people don't
understand the vision until they see it
that is that's a good one i think you're
gonna win that so we have the
beautiful maria menounos coming on
inside out you guys have probably seen
her face at least once in your life she
has had the most
incredible career i've ever seen i can
like go from she was on e news abc today
show then she goes to being on wwe she
now has her own podcast about mental
health and all the in physical health
and i mean she's interviewed obama's and
clinton's and it is
truly the most insane arc and her
parents are from greece um and they came
over and so she's just been working her
whole life and she has so much wisdom
and insight and we are so lucky to call
her a friend and i just am really
excited to ask her all these questions
and i don't think i've ever actually got
in depth with her about this stuff so
stay tuned
[Music]
today you guys we are so thrilled to
have someone on that we not only have
the biggest adoration for but we're
lucky enough to call a friend this greek
goddess is a familiar tv journalist and
presenter for cbs et extra e access
hollywood today show and appear as an
actress on so many films like tropic
thunder if you guys know that one we
love that one fantastic four i'm just
gonna throw back some things for you and
also tv shows like one tree hill scrubs
mindy project a wrestler on wwe she had
her own reality series was an author for
every girl's guide to life a host of the
inspiring beautiful podcasts better
together and that was literally just
scratching the surface y'all so she's
also won an emmy if that's not even cool
enough this is the wonderful maria
menino
[Applause]
what a great opening thank you
no i literally remember when i was
writing this up and i called my mom
after and i said
i forgot how incredible your career has
been and it still is so amazing like you
have been non-stop and and everything
you do you put 110 in and like if you
guys know her personally like she is one
of the sweetest souls you'll ever meet
no honestly my heart is fluttering just
the fact that you're sitting in this
room right now because
seriously we've always wanted to have
you on the show yeah since the beginning
of the unwax podcast but we literally
put you right up there with having our
parents on we wanted to make sure that
we were so prepared so confident in our
skills before having someone so
important to us to be here so thank you
for coming on we love you so much i love
you girls so much you're making me cry
i'm like holding it back because you're
making me i woke up today and i was like
i'm probably going to cry yeah
i'm going to pull my lashes off and
they're going to come off oh yeah
seriously and i think what's really
exciting is that i why we really wanted
you on the show as well as your well one
well spoken but you also have so much
insight into like everything involving
your career that i think you're going to
give such great advice health-wise
career-wise just
bettering yourself i don't know i just i
can't wait i'm like learning myself
right now i'm like so nervous
i want to dive right into your career
because we just listed such an
impressive resume of yours so impressive
but i think as you know sophina are
going through our 20s and i think a lot
of young people out there can relate
sometimes you don't always have a clear
vision of what you want to do and
sometimes you know we want to try
everything but we think we're spreading
ourselves too thin did you always
know what you wanted to do and you had
that in sight
so
it's such a tough thing because
i
i think i came from fear
growing up because we grew up poor we
grew up hard
and
i knew i wanted to be in la i knew i
wanted to be on tv
i knew i wanted to be in this industry
and i did love like joan london and
journalism and all of that but i also
wanted to act and i wanted to do fun
things but my parents were like no no no
no right so i was like okay my secret
plan is
i'm gonna go to school for broadcast
journalism so i went to emerson
and then
when i can just get away and cut the
umbilical cord
a little bit then i'll switch it on them
and i'll get to do all the other stuff
too yeah
and and the other thought in the back of
my head was oh the fear of failure was
okay if i fail at this i need like 50
backup plans
you sound like me to a t right that's
exactly that's how i feel all the time
is that you have this idea that okay you
want to pursue this thing but your
parents are just here to filter you a
little bit make sure oh like you can't
do this because they don't understand
that also maybe they don't want you to
fail
yeah and they you know joining an
industry that is so
cutthroat and competitive it's like they
almost want you to just be safe in
whatever you do but continue with what
you were saying yeah well because
they've seen
the hard hard hard parts and they're
like oh cause sometimes i feel like i
give bad advice because i'm so scared
for someone to go through the [ __ ] i
went through
right and and i had
you know i had a lot of good and i had
some tough times so i can see where you
want to protect yeah someone right but
yeah i wanted 50 backup plans so i was
like i'm gonna get good at everything so
smart and
i
i studied broadcast journalism then i
met kevin and i worked on his feature
film so i was like oh i'm gonna produce
movies i love producing i love
coordinating stuff
and then i got this opportunity through
someone on the on the movie uh that
kevin had to
submit my tape for channel one news
mm-hmm i was like oh my god this sounds
amazing it's like cnn for kids i'm gonna
travel
so kevin and i i remember we went to
forever 21 he helped me put my little
interview off it together wait a minute
oh yeah are you serious i mean i met
kevin when i was 19 you guys we've been
together my whole life that's like our
parents mom met dad when she was 19.
yeah oh did she realize she does
well so we went to forever 21 he put
like this cute he's like i'm thinking
like mtv meets cnn so we put that kind
of out there
and help me put it a reel together got
the job moved to l.a
and the gates of paramount were across
the street and i knew entertainment
tonight was being filmed over there
and i was like oh i would just kind of
look across the street so then somehow
this opportunity comes up there for me
to
report for them but host et on mtv i got
there
then like there were some acting things
like fantastic four so i was open to
everything and i did everything yeah
and then there were people who
like a friend of mine my assistant at
the time was like katie couric was
having lunch with my dad and she said
that you should focus on one thing and
that you're too spread out yeah
and
and then she said she thought about it
and she goes actually she's doing fine
wow and and so it's funny because
everyone has a different theory on it
right and i do see
how it is just
the most
amazing thing when you can just hone in
on one thing and get it like do it right
amazing
and i do see how hard it is when you're
so spread out
to be good at everything is really
challenging or to be exceptional you got
to do one thing
so i honestly think it's like you really
have to go with your heart because i am
kind of like a butterfly like i want to
just i want to be everyone i want to try
everything i want to do everything yeah
and so that spoke to me and kevin being
like the secret manager and the wizard
of oz behind the curtain he really is
was always diversify diversify diversify
and that has been the secret to my
success
um although i do feel happiest when i'm
doing one thing because multitasking is
very difficult
and wearing many hats is very difficult
so whenever i got to be on a set acting
because that was my like weakest
strength i feel like i would shut
everything down and i would just focus
and be very present right
and i loved it and it was so much fun
yeah maybe that's the secret is really
just being present with the specific
thing because i'm i mean sistine's also
this way we love trying everything like
it would be fun to act it'd be fun to
produce it'd be fun to do podcasting and
that's what we're kind of trying to do
right now and it's so frustrating when
someone says just focus on one thing
because i can't i'm like curious about a
hundred other things but it probably
just really takes you being present in
that one specific thing you're focused
on for you to be really good at it so it
doesn't take you having to just cut
everything else out and only focus on
podcasting or focus on journalism but i
also have to say it does says something
about your character yeah you're able to
have such a strong work ethic it's also
not easy it's not easy because it's so
you know i could say i want to develop
an app write a script be an actress
model but i could say i could do all
these things but you actually went out
and did all of these things and do you
think that you know you having a tough
upbringing and you didn't grow up with a
lot accounted for that yeah
you're you remind me so much of my mom
yeah where she grew up really hard she
grew up with nothing but there was some
fire in her gut i was just gonna say a
fire in the belly it just hit her and i
don't think a lot a lot everyone has
that like is it the fear that's
something
or just the you have this like blind
ambition that i want to just do this
like i remember guys growing up we
cleaned nightclubs in boston there was
one main nightclub called the channel it
was called boston's you know best hard
rock club and and it's like 2 000 people
i think fit in there yeah we were the
janitors and my parents didn't have
money for babysitters so we used to go
to work with them since i was a baby
right
and from the time we could
hold the broom and pitch in we were
pitching in we were cleaning because the
faster we got it done the faster we got
the heck out we got to the next place to
the next place to the next place um we
would get to go home
christmas easter thanksgiving
every single day there was never a day
off wow so the work ethic was built
there but also the dream was built there
because i had only one way to look and
that was up right this is i gotta find
out yeah i used to get up on the stage
where like the b-52s had performed the
night before and i would just like dream
about
whatever it was that i wanted to do
sounds like your parents were also very
hard-working right oh my god cause
they're they're immigrants from greece
yeah it's like i find that story i mean
you you're so beautiful i know your
parents like you know well they're the
sweetest people in the world um
but did you learn also from watching
them and being reinforced every single
day to work i learned watching how hard
my parents
worked
what it took to kind of survive and to
to do more but i mean i watched my dad
he would he was type 1 diabetic and he
was you know working so hard with manual
labor his blood sugars would drop into
like comas and we would be at the
hospital every week he'd rip the ivs out
of his body go back to work he stepped
on a nail they took the nail out of his
foot he went right back to work so what
did i do
when i got into this business i was i
had a really hard time
and i love helping young people in this
industry in the beginning because it's
like you get sucked into this vacuum
tornado and you don't know how
to handle even just feeding yourself
right so intense yeah and so i was in
that vacuum for a while and i was eating
fast food every day and i was totally
depleted and i knew i would end up in
the hospital oh my god low potassium
malnourishment whatever right but i
would rip the ivs out and go to work i
never would miss
ever i mean extreme situations and i
would never miss that is it speaks
volumes i mean pretty badass though yeah
i hear that a lot today i hear a lot of
complaining if there's a lot of work
that has to be done i hear a lot of
nagging i don't want to show up i'm
calling in sick and that is why you are
where you're at today yeah i mean with
such a successful crazy career what
would you say
is your proudest moment of your career
so far
ooh i can't say it without crying but
stop sorry
my proudest moment was exactly why i
wanted to succeed so
i told kevin because he asked me when i
first met him because why do you want to
succeed why do you want this so bad and
i said i want to give my parents the
life they never had
and so i was able to give my parents the
life they never had i mean they came
from a village with no running water
no shoes nothing they didn't have
toothbrushes and so i took them
everywhere they were my american express
card
i took them to the emmys i took them to
the oscars i took them on yachts i took
them on private planes i took them
everywhere and anywhere to experience
the other side and bought them a house
bought them a car like every dream they
could have had and more
that's what i'm most proud of
um
yes of course i'm proud that you know a
little greek girl from medford
you know wrote a new york times
bestselling book or won an emmy and all
of that but
those are like
those are super cool yeah
but the best was definitely definitely
that getting to enjoy it with my parents
and getting to spoil them yeah and i
feel like that's i mean that just is the
reason why i think you are successful is
that your
your
drive wasn't from there's a surface
level
you had that fire in your belly you had
that passion in your heart i know it
sounds like super cheesy but that was
one thing that pushed you to go forward
and say i can do everything and i want
to do everything just although my
parents are saying no
i want to be able to provide them this
stuff that they're never going to get to
experience unless i do it and you did it
and i mean i i just i'm looking at your
career at every single level and you
have just killed it at every angle and
it's i mean they probably could not have
been more proud of you yeah my mom
always said like mario we can't believe
all the things
i was like how do you do it every day
like they were just so shell-shocked
we don't even know what to say like we
don't know how to explain any of this
also is that you you really emphasized a
couple times about kevin and your family
and i feel like do you think that also
having a really good circle around you
because you can say to yourself when i
can say to myself or sistine or anybody
that this is what i want to do when i
want to try everything
but sometimes in your head you can get
kind of stuck in it and wrapped up in
and you can be a perfectionist and then
maybe kevin or your mom or your dad
would tell you
no do it or you can do it do you you
contribute or
yeah absolutely
i think that one thing my dad always
said and it stuck so hard was maria you
can do anything you put your mind to
right and i believed him
and so
i had them even though my dad
was not supportive he was very scared
right yeah my mom was and she was she
was so good at like she drove me
everywhere she took me to everything she
believed in me
um and then i met kevin and then i had
kevin so sistine when you get down on
yourself not trying not being able to do
everything
no i also had another me next to me
helping me
so i couldn't have done everything i did
without having kevin next to me as well
right you know we joked when we were
writing the book for example i was doing
access hollywood the today show nightly
news sometimes some dateline stuff
that's cool i loved it so to the today
show from l.a i had to get up at one in
the morning
so i barely would sleep i'd get maybe
three hours of sleep then i'd have to go
do the today show and then start the
whole day all over again so
though that wasn't every single day yeah
um it was a lot and when i was writing
the first book
kevin and i had this whole thing we
would go to the mall we'd outline the
book so we were at the the cafeteria
there so we could keep getting endless
food go to the bathroom whatever never
have to stop
and then i had the chapters and so i
would go in in the middle of the night
when it was quiet and then my only time
and i would write
and then the next morning i would email
it to him and he's like you just gave me
a pile of [ __ ] i gotta clean up he's
like
and i was like what
honest
that's what it is being honest
or at least he's giving his input if he
was just saying you yeah we're good at
everything you're good at everything i
mean that's like my mom she always goes
you want
you want me to be nicer do you want the
truth and i'm like all right hit us with
the truth and that is how
we adjust and we pivot and we need
people like
jennifer and kevin's in our life
to really
help us because sometimes brutal honesty
is the best and i love talk we love
talking about love and dating and we
love seeing like oh what are green flags
and what are things we want like
what do we what do we want in a guy to
help us kevin is a walking group my
thing is thinking that you really found
someone that is your true support system
and like how did you know that it he
would be that
longevity in your career and everything
you are today
i
knew he was the one like the first time
i met him
and
yeah like the second i met him i knew it
was done and then by day three
that was when you could sit at the gate
at the airport with somebody
definitely like a long time ago yeah he
was telling me how he took massage
therapy classes to help his dad's pain
from cancer and i was like you're a
caretaker i was like that's it that's
it's done that i'm gonna make you fall
in love with me i was a chubby 19 year
old i was 40 pounds heavier and i was
like i'm gonna make you fall in love
with me stop and you're good i won i did
and
who would have known by the way at that
point i'm 19 that i was gonna need a
caretaker someday that i was gonna have
yeah a huge kind of issue yeah um and
not only did he take care of me he took
care of my mom he's taking care of my
dad he is he is a caretaker so you met
him when you were 19. when did you
really
jump into your career in broadcasting tv
and all that right after that i mean i
worked on his film
a producer named mark finney who was on
the film told kevin he was paying at
this place called channel one news yeah
he's like maria should you know submit a
resume they're looking for someone
and so that was the beginning and then
from there you know the rest is history
see sometimes you don't think that you
need a caretaker but when you don't even
realize how much you're taking care of
everyone else so having someone like
kevin in your corner being like i got
you babe like i can do this i can take a
little bit of the load off is
so nice yeah well you jumped into your
career and it's been such a long one but
what do you do at those roadblocks when
it doesn't work when you get rejection
or you have self-doubt because i know
that you can have someone championing
for you in your corner but sometimes
that can just get overwhelming or do you
take it personally so do you have a
routine or something that you do when
you don't work yeah rejection is hard
yeah like when we'll go out and pitch
something and you know for me
i just didn't have a lot of gas in the
tank to
to
to deal with it i feel like so i don't
think i dealt with the rejection really
well i think i i also didn't have a lot
of time to focus on it either because i
was in this like
you know 24 7. yeah um it's something
that i'm actually working on being more
resilient now
because i'm i have a little bit more
space and time but yeah
one of the things that's been hitting me
lately was um because i just went to
this insane
meditation event that like changed my
life was when we're young
i think we're
we're constantly dreaming right
and i think in those moments when we're
dreaming we're actually feeling it
right like what would it be like if i
could you know do this and what would it
be like if i could have that and
so
what's interesting is that's like
the basis for manifesting right so when
i look back at my life i used to dream
of
all these things and and even the the
physical things like i'm gonna have a
house that's gonna be so big it's gonna
look like the white house and then i'm
gonna have the and i was at a porsche
dealership once and this guy was making
fun of us for even being in there and
i'm like i'll be back i'm gonna have one
of these one day
my mom would try to teach me how to do
the the chores in the house i'm like mom
i'm gonna have a housekeeper i don't
know what you're talking about i don't
need to learn all this
and everything happened you manifested
everything the house looks like it has
the white columns yeah okay so
everything yeah everything full
supporter and visualizing what you want
and then you'll get it but it's not just
visualizing so what dr joe dispenza
teaches and esther hicks and the wayne
dyers they all talk about it like you
have to you have to
have a clear intention like i want a
million dollars but if you don't believe
that you can have it there's the block
and it won't come so the flow comes to
you you have to believe but then dr joe
dispenza says you have to create the
emotion
of having it before you even have it
that's hard for the wi-fi signal to go
out so gratitude is the ultimate state
of receivership
your body doesn't know the difference
between having it and not having it
right because it feels like it already
has it so then the universe has to
deliver it oh
and so
what i realized is when i was younger i
was dreaming and dreaming and dreaming
then i got it
then it was like
the tornado yeah and then the [ __ ] comes
and then the traumas come and then
people abuse you and all these horrible
things happen and then you
you're sick
right and then you're like oh i stopped
dreaming
oh i'm actually blocking myself for more
success because i feel like i don't
deserve more
oh i'm scared of more because more means
more pain right because look at the pain
so now you're associating the things
that you've wanted with pain i do that
all the time i do that all the time and
i feel like especially right now
you know i don't know about sophia but
i'll speak for the both of us we are
constantly facing these mental blocks
and these mental walls and we're telling
ourselves you can't do it you can't make
that you can't develop that you're never
going to sell that
but who says that we can't us yeah and
then we're the only reason so how did
you you're the block how did you break
down those walls because i need help so
i'm telling you guys this event i just
came from literally changed my whole
life
so i had dr joe dispenza on my show
years ago
he's uh he's an incredible
scientist and
has devoted his life to neuroscience so
where esther hicks is getting downloads
from abraham yeah
and you kind of have to have a leap of
faith to believe right
joe is all science
and so he healed his back after a
massive car crash
where they said he was going to be
paralyzed he healed it with his mind he
reconstructed every vertebrae with his
mouth
that's him i read about this somewhere
yeah oh my god i heard my mom told me
this one time when i was
i had my second heart surgery and i
remember her in the hospital saying
think in your head that it's being
healed that your chest bone is being
healed actually and i got out of the
hospital in five days no the craziest i
swear to god i remember this so clearly
there's no way that because they cracked
your chest bone open yeah there's no way
that you could walk the day after i
don't even know if it was 24 hours later
you were you were like running down the
halls my mom said that you believed her
yes i you said in bed as well while you
were lying in the hospital bed you said
i don't want to be here i want to walk
and i'm going to get stronger and you
just keep saying that that's yourself
and that was from him so our thoughts
are very powerful yeah so you change
your thoughts you change your life
and
what you believe will be and so when i
was in this event
i was realizing and it hit me really
fast i'm like oh my god
i'm the illness it's me mm-hmm only way
to heal me is to change my thoughts
which will change my reality yeah and so
if you want to get out of your own way
which is really hard because we're in
this non-stop cycle we wake up we do the
same things we're hustling we're
thinking about tomorrow we think about
next week we're going to see the same
people doing the same things he says
you can overlap each day and you
wouldn't know the difference because our
thoughts are dragging us into the past
right so we're being controlled by the
emotions of the past oh well that's
happened last time so this is what's
going to happen now yeah and then your
future thoughts are where do i gotta go
where do i go to be whatever there's no
space for the magical or the unknown to
come to us right
and so he talks about the only way is to
get into and reprogram your subconscious
and we get into
you know that black space where you are
just consciousness and you can plant the
seeds in the fields right and then sep
and then you delete kind of this you you
you break the separation between time
and space yeah by attracting that
thought because we're magnets
right we are and so you put it out there
and
and then it will show up in the most un
unbelievable and unknown ways does it
take being present and meditating does
it take writing because it is hard just
to
i mean i i used to do meditation and i i
have a great full journal that i write
in every day um and it seems like it's
working but sometimes because of just
the way my brain works i'm definitely
someone who thinks in the past and
someone that thinks way in the future
yeah and then i feel like the last few
weeks have flown by it's like the end of
oh it's like halfway through may and i
it's you're just on autopilot yeah and
that's why
you're and you'll continue getting
frustrated and you won't feel good
because you don't and you don't know why
so i fully immersed for seven days i
didn't use my phone
and i just went all in
and
i think that if you want to figure out
how to change your life you've got to go
into that black space and you have to be
um present and the first course i did
i'll tell you it was early february or
end of january my friend was like you've
got to do this i have a feeling this is
what you need
so i did this course called the formula
on dr joedispensa.com yeah and in three
days my anxiety was completely gone
wait guys can i take this i had just
called my doctor and asked him for
medication i said i don't think i can
live in this body anymore i'm i'm losing
my mind
i had just lost my mom months before
and it was like you know very painful
and
in three days i was like did someone
give me a tranquilizer i wasn't
clenching i wasn't grinding i wasn't
chewing the insides of my mouth my
tongue you guys was stuck to the roof of
my mouth i couldn't unstick it
oh my god and it's been gone ever since
oh my god three days of the formula and
by the way it's like a 12-hour course i
still had plenty of course to go i need
to i need this course i injected my
veins yeah that's amazing it's amazing
so then when i went to the event he kept
giving like people go to these events
and they heal themselves of cancer head
to toe i watched people get out of
wheelchairs and walk no watched people i
mean look at the chills no
people with parkinson's and all sides
all kinds of unbelievable um
uh
success stories and testimonials
because the body once you
surrender and you give it what it needs
which is like
some clean space and some you know um
the help what comes from the the
chemicals from meditating
the ig i think it's the iga levels and
your autoimmune system go up like an ex
like extreme amount right and your body
starts healing
so
the formula is a great entree into what
he does
and there are meditations attached so i
started doing the meditations every day
every day i got addicted there was no oh
my god i have to it was i can't wait
wait to get in there and i'm not a
meditator me neither and i'm afraid that
i can't sit still for five minutes
she then told me after i did the formula
she goes there's an event coming up you
should we should go yeah i'll let go a
meditation event kill me there's no way
i can't do a a week are you high
yeah and so
i did it
i did a five-hour meditation hold up at
4 00 a.m
oh five hours five hours me i can't
meditate my body should have and by the
way it doesn't do you're not you don't
stop person like you go go go i did it
did it feel amazing it was amazing by
the way
the entire week we were up at three in
the morning
and we meditated we would break he does
a human it's a very humane schedule yeah
like you meditate then you he lectures
and you met at their breaks
i never once was tired that week which
i'm always complaining about being
exhausted me too yeah but guess what
when you say it you feel it
then
i never had enough time i don't have
enough time i don't have time
guys i'm waking up at the same time to
get ready to come here today i'm waking
up at the same time that i normally
would and i normally would be racing
till the last second
i had an extra hour this morning
there's endless time for me now because
i'm not stressing about not having time
this is like i have time you have to
it's all about shifting your mindset
it's like we constantly as i think it's
human nature you always just look at the
glass half full yeah i mean half empty
and you're like oh man like i can't
believe i have to drive all the way down
here i have to hit traffic i have to
find parking and instead it's being like
how great that i get to see people i
have a conversation i have experiences i
need this meditation it's also just
realizing that we
we have time i think that we just forget
and that's why our days blend into
months and our months blends into years
is because we're just going through flow
we're almost in a state of flow but the
wrong type of flow yeah and it's just
kind of like a robotic type and
sitting with yourself for whatever it is
like waking up in the morning meditating
and having that stillness in your mind
just right when you wake up
sets the tone for the whole day and you
can go okay i can go through my routine
and actually be conscious about what
you're doing in your routine because
it's it's very easy to wake up like i do
the same thing where i don't like the
unpredictable so i'm very predictable
with my morning routine and it's not
always the best because it could be
sometimes ruin everything else and i
could be doing something else you're not
allowing anything to come in when you're
so scared of the unknown yes and
supposed to embrace the unknown i know
because if i let it go maybe something
amazing can happen that day because i
didn't you know let the vibration you're
not focusing you're already ready for
this no i can feel it because
you're saying the stuff he's saying or
he's like your months become years and
your years become you're already saying
the same stuff he says you're in it
that's why i understand because i used
to do abraham hicks if you guys don't
know who that is she's i've only used
her youtube but she's really good at
getting your mind set and it's more
it's it's meditation it's also
visualization it's putting the things
out there that you want but really
feeling it thinking it everything
believing it
and i remember i was doing that a lot
during quarantine because i was so
stressed but i found such a
peace and excitement for what was gonna
come after quarantine because i was just
able to feel oh this is what's gonna
happen right after like this is like i
didn't need anyone to tell me i just saw
it and look it's happening and look it's
happening and i mean that was year like
not even that long ago but it's like i
wish i kept it going but it does you can
it yeah i know you need to i just feel
like a lot of people don't realize this
and you put it in such great words
because it's hard to place
what that feeling is of going through
your emotions you don't even there's not
a word for it yeah we're all doing it
we're so unconscious and no one notices
until someone tells you yeah change it
up yeah if you're unhappy change that
like yeah change your pattern do
something different in the morning
change the way you start your morning
change the the way you you do things go
on an adventure like spontaneously
you can't keep doing the same thing and
expecting different results
what would you say is a first step for
people people often feel like you know
they're in a rut they're stuck they
could be listening to this and saying
meditation won't help me yeah well
because also
the meditations that are out there are
really hard for people yeah because i've
tried a lot of them
and there are some
but
the only thing i have found and i've
been doing this intensely for let's say
five years i've been really into health
and wellness with my show that yeah you
talked about earlier
um i devote every single day to getting
better right right
and i've had everyone on and i've tried
everything he is
completely teaching you how to reprogram
your mind your thoughts and your and
your brain and your in your life yeah
you're reprogramming it's not just sit
in black space and just whatever
that's great if you can do it
um but i'd rather
be active and active participant in
creating my life and we are the creators
of our life yeah and once we realize
that then we know we can create it for
good or we can create it for bad right
and then if you start to follow your
thoughts like i started playing like
catcher
um because i did the formula first so
that is the entree i think if anyone's
listening to this and they're inspired
and they want to try something or you're
feeling like
you know is this all there is in life
like i can't do this this is i'm not
happy
try the formula
then there's a course called the
progressive so the progressive is um the
next course i had to do in order to go
to this retreat you have to have the
language you have to have the vocabulary
you have to have the basics down when
you go into this advanced meditation
week so i did this progressive course
and i'm telling you every single day
i did it i got happier and lighter and
happier and i kept telling kevin i go
i feel like i could lift a car just with
a smile like my happiness like i don't
know what's happening to me
but i feel amazing
and then i immersed for the seven days
and what's great about the seven days so
like the first day i was there we went
into a meditation now i'm like
so precious at this point with my
meditations i can't hear a sound don't
make any noises i gotta have the right
chair
yeah right because because we're not
trained yet
so i get there and this woman next to me
falls on me because she just had this
like whole experience then the bracelets
are jiggling and all of this is
distracting me and i'm getting
frustrated because my meditation is
being interrupted and i can't get back
in and
yeah right and then you realize
oh
i think i need to fix this about myself
oh
i have an issue here it's she's the
teacher now i need to realize
that i'm making my sick every day with
this kind of little annoyances
and so that was like one big lesson
and then
once i started
opening my heart i didn't know how to
open my heart he teaches you how to open
your heart i started loving myself i
didn't know i didn't love myself i
didn't know how to love myself i just
learned how to love myself
and what happened was insane like my
heart you guys was going
no way boom
boom ah what the freak is happening you
like felt your heart physically like
expanding and loading and expanding i
mean i don't know why anyone wouldn't
want to try this yeah it was it was so
transformative
and so then when you when i accessed
that
i started to realize that
okay so like there's so many things
you've heard in life right if you
believe you're gonna die when you get a
diagnosis is what do you believe and
that's what's gonna happen
but you don't really sit in it to
understand the root and the underneath
part so
when my heart started opening i realized
oh my god love is the only answer but
people say that but you don't know it
you don't understand it and then you
like there's like the hippie world where
you're like love and peace and you're
like i can't get there i don't
understand
so much that the word becomes like
something that's not meaningless like
cliche yeah yeah but when i started to
apply it in multiple different ways
throughout the week because again i had
nothing else to do other than just be in
this space yeah there was a moment where
another woman fell on me
and because it's got no attraction to
people
she's like
i'll catch you
so
now instead of being frustrated i went
into my heart
and
it was it was a beautiful experience
because i'm helping her even i'm trying
to meditate at the same time but i'm
helping her and my heart was just
pounding i i had another experience
where i was having a pain
and i said oh god what am i going to do
this is going to interfere now with
what's about to happen
so i said hmm
what if i go into my heart and i go into
gratitude
let's see what happens
and the pain just
went away
i was like wait what
and i've since applied it every time i
had like these leg cramps the other
night and i started panicking and i'm
like all right i got to look up online
how to fix
oh no i'm going to try this and i tried
it and it worked it works every time oh
my gosh stop it
is inside of us i think we underestimate
how powerful our bodies and minds minds
are yeah it really is that i mean yeah
and don't you like i wish at the time
because you've gone through i mean so
many health you've had a huge health
scare you had your brain too i don't
know if anyone knew this but she was
diagnosed with it it was benign right
brain tumor brain tumor and you went
through surgery and don't you just wish
that sometimes like you had that
information at that time because maybe
that would have helped with some of the
pain that you were going through um i
had
a lot of big epiphanies around the tumor
diagnosis to me it was a gift instantly
i was going to ask you what you've
because
how's your mind so yeah like how was
your mindset when you found out like
after and everything well
a few months before my mom had been
diagnosed with a brain tumor so my mom
got stage four brain cancer in september
how are the odds of that happening it's
like lightning striking researchers have
said it's like lightning strikes and
your daughter
is not connected not connected at all
but when you do the joe dispenza work
one of my final breakthroughs was oh my
god it was in the field and i asked for
it and that's why i got it because i
remember my mom was having a hard time i
think it was right after
she got her first rounds of radiation
and i said god i wish you gave this to
me i could handle it better oh
oh maria
because it's harder to see someone else
go for her that you love and you're like
i'd rather take it and then you get it
she's like i wish i could take the pain
away and like take and deal with it yeah
and so yeah two of our dogs got brain
tumors what so then i realized that this
event oh my god it's been in our field
and that's that's what i have to delete
so i would go into the field
and i'm planting in like you know mind
body soul healing all the stuff anyway
it's really profound when you do the
work and you start to see how in control
we are of our lives yeah and
and
it's just about making different choices
but you have to get to a place and
that's why i think full immersion in an
event or taking the online course people
have healed themselves of cancer just
taking the courses online that's insane
because the body just completely changes
you discover these courses before or
after your diagnosis uh
after i think it was before i
interviewed joe but i was so deep and
caretaking from my mom you were just
that i couldn't really yeah i was so
confused
when you found out your diagnosis
alongside having to take care of your
mom at the same time like how that i
mean that's a lot of pressure yeah to
have on one person and then also your
career
you have a husband it's just like
there's so many things going on in your
life like how did you
handle that i mean it was crazy because
i diagnosed myself mm-hmm
i said to the doctor i go i think i have
a brain tumor like my mom
how did you know i was sometimes i felt
it when i was present in his office for
the first time so i sat in his office
i'm like i have this really bad ear pain
i think i have an ear infection it's so
strange mm-hmm he checked my ear he
cause you don't have an ear infection i
said
he's like what else are you feeling i'm
like well i've been getting really bad
headaches on set oh i'm slurring my
speech
oh
i think i have a brain tumor like my mom
and he's like i
let's get an mri we got an mri and i
just knew that day i took a picture of
myself in the hospital gown i go this is
the moment i become a patient i know it
and then he called me
my mom's tumor had just come back with a
vengeance oh my gosh i was at in mexico
uh with kevin um setting her up to do
these holistic treatments yeah
and he called me he's like i can't even
believe i have to make this call i can't
even believe what i'm about to say to
you i go don't worry i already know he's
like what i go i have a brain tumor
right he said yeah i said okay what kind
is it what do we know and i took the
notes i called my mom surgeon and i said
hey i need to schedule an appointment
and they're like for your mom right i oh
no for me was everyone just floored
floored yeah florida were you and were
you in a state of shock at this point
like i actually don't believe that's
true i was in shock kevin and i he
wasn't with me when i got the the call
he had just gone to the corner store so
he came back and go we need to go
outside right now so we sat outside in
the parking lot
and i turned the cameras on me right
away because i wanted to remember that
moment
and so i'm used to filming myself as a
journalist and all of that and
documenting so i documented it
and i said so i just got diagnosed with
a brain tumor holy [ __ ]
um before i sat down i called my lawyer
who's like my best friend i said i'm
never gonna work again am i i'm screwed
how am i gonna take care of my mom how
am i gonna take care of everybody right
and he's like let's just keep this close
to the vest for now let's get through
surgery and let's figure out what we say
to people later
and that was really great advice
and he's like my brother so it was like
it was like calling a family member but
it was scary when you're calling
somebody and you're thinking then you're
not realizing the plan for the worse
it's you think in your head okay i am
i've done wwe i'm in physical top shape
i am
a presenter like i am physically
verbally everything is
a you thought at its peak
and you just realize the fragility of
life when this just hits you and you go
wait i i'm not
as
no not you are strong but like i'm not i
didn't realize that this stuff can
happen to me you know you never think
it's gonna ever happen to you until it
does or yeah well i thought it was just
stress from taking care of my mom
every symptom i was feeling
and it made sense that that would be
that but i also was so burnt at that
point
um
and
burnt out by everything i was dealing
with in in the work world and the
toxicities i had dealt with and yeah and
of course dealing with the
the trauma of like taking care of my mom
and all of that
i was like is this my get out of jail
free card oh my gosh you were like maybe
there's a lot of toxicity and work and
stuff yeah in terms of like so you
looked at it almost like maybe i can
just sit and breathe for a second no
maybe like this is it and i'm going like
let's go i'm tired i'm cooked it's been
a great life yeah yeah i cause i went
home and my housekeeper was like my
second mom
um
i told her and she's you know
hysterically crying and i'm not
and she's like why are you not crying
i'm like because i don't care like
that's it like i
i don't really care i'm i'm so exhausted
i'm so
i was
really broken by all of the bad
experiences that i had gone through
you're like what good is there to look
for and then at some point i kind of was
just like
oh no this isn't the right feeling i'm
like i i had a kinesiologist come to the
house and he's like how you doing kiddo
and i'm like i'm just dying to be me
and he said oh did you read the book
and i go no and the book is amazing by
the way
um
and then i realized oh this is a gift
for me to change my life because i am
living an old dream i'm trapped in an
old dream this isn't my dream
i am i i've got to redefine success i've
gotta change the path so that it fits
who i am now and also um i can't i can't
survive at this pace and the way i was
treating myself what was the environment
you were in previously
was it just
was it just a lot of work was it people
that were just manipulating was it i
feel like sometimes you end up in places
you don't belong
and maybe they're supposed to be your
teachers and you don't know it at the
time but i think you know for me i was
working with people who were
cruel beyond reason for you know and i
just i was
i didn't have healthy boundaries i
didn't know i'm just learning my
boundaries now and we've been doing lots
of episodes on this on my show and it's
been really helpful right um i didn't
have boundaries
i
was just that puppy that was like what
else can i do to make you happy right
right and they took advantage of that
yeah and but it's my fault too right
because i should have been confident in
who i was and what i was bringing
and my value yeah and when you don't see
your own value how are they going to see
it
and so there's like this little loop
that happens yeah and so i need to kind
of stop the ride and and change some
stuff up and i've really focused on
you know manifesting really positive
experiences and i can say that i've
really only had positive experiences
since
um and
and working with people who see me not
are trying to make me not see me because
a lot of the times in life if you work
with the wrong people
they're going to really work hard
to tell you you're something you're not
and then you start to believe them and
that's the critical part because you
start to believe oh maybe i'm not good
or maybe i do suck or maybe i am
all these things that they're saying and
then you get you know in this confusion
tunnel of like
what
i don't understand yeah and then
you know you kind of lose yourself you
lose yourself in it and especially i
feel like with this industry it's really
easy because the whole idea is
finding your image and then people
telling them like satisfaction of other
people yeah they're satisfied with you
if they like you then you'll work but if
you know your value
you're going to demand your value yeah
and that's going to come out of their
pocket
and so what they have to do is they have
to keep i'm going to be crass they have
to keep [ __ ] on you yeah to lower
you right right i had so many people who
tried to give me bad advice so that
i didn't have to demand what i deserved
what was the worst advice you've gotten
uh i had one boss tell me i should stop
being on magazine covers and stop doing
all this other stuff you know you're
gonna just focus on this one thing and
get rid of all this other [ __ ] and blah
blah blah and i'm like
so this other [ __ ] is why you hired me
because i was different than everyone
else and now you're telling me to be the
same because i would have deserved more
money because that's because if now you
can put me in their category then i only
deserve what they have and people's
knowledge is only going to go so far
they don't know you they only know the
knowledge of you from what they've
talked to you how they've spent time
with you or
and they want to
keep you in the image of their head now
that's what i'm saying yeah they want to
write down keep you down there they're
like maria
higher than this we don't want to get
your ego to get too big because then
you're going to demand things going to
demand money we don't want you to do
that i got a massive deal at one one
place
and the boss told me that i was a
terrible interviewer
uh they told me and i was like i think
you're paying me eight figures um okay
and i've had the most massive interviews
of all time even
you know i mean i was gonna ask you
questions even about those insane
interviews with like presidents like
and so it's crazy so the same people who
are paying me an extraordinary amount of
money to do this job
are knocking me down so many pegs and
saying you need to earn the job that i
actually have in my contract yeah yeah
they're like no no no you got to earn
this and i'm like wait a second you just
hired me to do this job but how does
that make sense it didn't that's the
point so they make you insane and then
you get a brain tumor
don't let people tell you who
they think you are i know you have to
get so rooted in who you are
what you do what your value is yeah and
you gotta own it and don't worry about
people calling you a diva because that's
all i worried about and then guess what
i was so unfucking diva yeah that they
killed me by the way
by the way we say this all the time if
demanding things as a woman makes you a
[ __ ] then fine i'll be the bitchiest
[ __ ] you've ever seen yes can we make
t-shirts let's be [ __ ] [ __ ]
because if that means that i know who i
am know my worth and i won't get walked
on then fine and i've got my boundaries
yes and that's it i think it's so
important because you don't not only do
you have to apply that to your job you
can apply that to your friendships your
relationships your family dynamic if you
live your life in the vision of other
people
then you're gonna be screwed yeah you're
gonna literally lose yourself you're
setting yourself up for failure yeah so
that's why i transitioned into hosting
my own show yes every single day better
together with maria menounos where every
single day i am committed to getting
better right alongside the audience so
that we
and you guys who are listening because
we have you know all ages that listen
i'm like please don't wait till you get
a brain tumor please don't wait till
you're in your 40s or your 50s to get to
here you have to start learning this in
your 20s because everything from there
on will be a completely different
journey you're always going to have your
lumps as you know yeah and always you
know sunshine and rainbows
you're always going to have your lumps
but
you have to be so sturdy in who you are
and if you start cultivating that young
and you start cultivating practices and
you acquire the tools you need to get
through these tough moments right right
like my moment with your dad my first
words out of surgery was his quote from
rocky balboa and i sent him the video i
said if you now didn't if you didn't
know before this how much your words
carried me through my tough times that
broke him yeah yeah
truly no i really did i remember the
moment he watched it and he lost it and
he doesn't ever like he loves you and i
it's just oh god i was gonna start
crying i started talking about this no
but you it's it's it's just a testament
to show how strong you are and you need
to remember who you are at the core and
that life is going to hit you hard and
hard just like this quote
but it's how many times you fall it's
how many times you can get back up and
keep moving forward and i know that
sounds so cool cheesy and stuff but it's
true it's true yeah it's so true i think
it's incredible that you really made it
your life's work to just
better yourself
and i think that's something people
always neglect themselves they always
put themselves second they want to help
other people but sitting with yourself
and doing what's right for you is just
so important and i like love your
podcast i've listened to countless
episodes
you guys must listen to it better
together where does it stream everywhere
uh yeah there were a few better together
so you got to find the one with me
better together with maria manuel maria
and it's on apple podcast spotify
youtube it's wherever you get and
perfect shows
but yeah yeah you got to get better we
got to get better we got it yeah choose
you we could sit here
i was going to say i can like talk to
you
you and kevin have such a special place
in our hearts yeah it is like insane the
fact that you came here today and also
like you gave me words that i really
needed yeah i really needed them so i
really
you can have more any time you want you
have myself just text me any time
okay well if you have anything else
coming up plug it in oh wait the pin
tavern
wait so can i just say so i come back
from this meditation event i'm floating
i'm like oh my god
i'm just like oh my god this is amazing
yeah and i had to go basically right to
um
this premiere so i've been doing my
meditations i'm so devoted
uh the pineal gland meditation is like a
really big meditation he teaches and you
have to do it between 1 and 4 a.m
because your melatonin is the highest
girls i've been waking up at 2 30 or 3
in the morning every night doing a
90-minute meditation me every day every
day but guess what when you're done
you get into your bed and it feels like
a magical cloud
and i wake up and i'm happy and i feel
great and i have endless time and then i
do another one during the day and
sometimes i do one before bed when i go
to bed too so i'm meditating like
multiple hours a day now what if you're
a little what if you're a little drunk
and you went out last night and you're
like with your girls how do you get up
at 1am and do it okay hold up because i
did it this week see that's the question
um i had the premiere of the pentavarite
yeah um the other night i got home it
was a little after midnight and i said
all right this is your test so i set the
alarm no you do for 3 30 a.m
because it's between one and four so i
was like okay i'll cut it close i'll do
it at 3 30.
and i woke up and i did it and i had to
wake up two and a half hours later and i
was totally fine no totally fine and it
feels amazing and i wouldn't never ever
ever think of
and i know you're sitting here and
you're like it's not going to be me but
trust me it will be i need that because
i need to drive you slept on a cloud i
woke up in night sweats
like how many of us are waking up in the
middle of the night and then just
sitting there why not try it why not
your eyes are closed anyway in the
meditation but i'll tell you the effects
so here i've been doing it and it led up
to the premiere of the pentavert so
last february
i had come to la for a quick two days
and we had just found out my mom wasn't
gonna make it it was a terrible time
mike myers calls me personally to ask me
if i would consider being in his
netflix series he wrote this role for me
and i'm like mike are you kidding me
i'll shine your shoes i'll get you your
coffee this is like a dream come true of
course anything so i do it
he calls me months later to tell me how
funny i was and i'm like are you
freaking punching me you know like
what's going on
like i could die now mike myers thinks
i'm funny and call me to tell me giggles
okay yeah so
that aside i go to the premiere
and
you know it's like those things are like
always like yeah you go you take
pictures on the carpet yeah um and
someone grabs me and says oh we're doing
cast photos so i go outside i do cast
photos ken jong
and michael key and um
and mike all proceed to tell me
how i get the biggest laughs they're
freaking out telling me how great i was
and i'm like wait am i living in an
alternate universe i have a very teeny
role in this guys so it was so over the
top you're a scene stealer that then
yeah then
um kelly ripa's manager comes up to me
and he goes maria did you were you at
the q a today and i go no he's like mike
loves you and i'm like what are you
talking about he's like he was being
interviewed by david o russell and he
went on and on for like 20 minutes about
how brilliant you were in this and i'm
like all right i got to see this i'm
excited
and i'm building it up and i'm i don't i
don't understand what's happening but i
think it's the energy it is yeah i
believe it is it i believe so is and
that's like oh my god it's like they see
that every stuff is happening that i'm
not
that is just happening because you're
making my energies change yeah you're
protecting it yes yes you are because i
don't think kevin you saw at least two
episodes yesterday did i deserve the
amount of praise i got at that premiere
the other night
he's like should i be honest with my
wife right now
yes in a sense because it's really hard
to play yourself okay but the way you
put this kind of uh ironic
twist on it give yourself some
strategies
but you can't
aren't able to do that okay yeah that's
true that is you can see in your eye
you could see the sarcasm
i love it oh my gosh but i'm telling you
it's this stuff because we drove home
and i go kevin it's the best thing ever
i don't think
that this would have happened if i
hadn't just come out of this thing and
the energy that i'm putting out there
right and like i said all the things
that are happening like i had a moment
when i was getting ready in the morning
and i looked outside and i saw kevin had
two sun hats out there and i'm like look
at him he bought two he didn't just need
one he got two and i say that because in
our relationship i'm the one who's
always terrified about money yeah
because i grew up hearing we don't have
money we don't have money we don't have
money right and kevin is normal yeah
right i am the psycho who won't stop at
7 11 to get a water because i'm like
it's free at home right
i'm crazy and i sat and i realized wow
i've spent 24 years
being psycho scared of money
he hasn't and i got myself sick
see
you gotta think about what your thoughts
are yeah and so and then the last thing
i'll leave you with because this was
super important too this is a crazy
realization
so here's our energy tank yeah right
now cause it's a coffee but here's our
energy reserve for the day how do you
want to use it do you want to use it
stressing about your past do you want to
use it worrying about your future do you
want to use it being frustrated or angry
at something yeah because it's just
going down going down going down going
down going down and then you have no
time nothing left to create right you
have nothing left to create your life
because who's going to create it for you
you're on autopilot the only person
that's going to do it is your thoughts
and if you have no energy left you have
nothing to do it with and you have
nothing to have fun with there's no
energy for fun there's no energy for
anything that's where the sickness the
sadness the anxiety comes from and then
you're running on fumes yeah the engine
in a car is going to cease if you don't
have gas in it right pick and choose
what you want to dwell on so every day i
look at my cup and i'm like
i wake up and i s and i do my grateful
list with the dogs and i say and i call
all the dogs i'm like kids are you ready
to do the gratefulness
and whoever shows up shows up when he's
always there we're grateful lord for
bringing us together and making us a
family and for our health and and i go
through the whole list and baby talk
and then i i say now who do we want to
be today
and so i'm like i want to be light and
happy and i want to be the light and i
want to feel the light and i want to
feel light yeah and i i
set my intention on what i want to be
yeah and then at night i say how did i
do tonight
how did i do today and i'm like okay i
did really well with this you know some
thoughts krypton oh but i caught them
and i shifted them okay all right well
tomorrow i'm gonna do better at this
this was one thing i think i slipped on
i'm gonna do better with this oh so
you're always like always checking in
i'm staying conscious
but remember your energy reserve energy
where do you want to use it because yeah
yeah you're worrying about stuff you
can't control anyway
so why not put that energy towards
building your future
and and trust me it's so much more
constructive but you're going to feel
better which means you're going to
attract all that
accolades that i don't even think i
deserved at the cadaver premiere but
anyway washington tower because mike
myers is a freaking genius
he plays 80 000 different characters and
every time i'm like wait that was him
too yeah i'm like what no no that's you
next next
different characters so
you have given so many people the best
advice ever and everyone can totally
put this into their own lives and i
think that people need sometimes a
wake-up call or a reminder because we're
all like cars we need engines we need to
oil up fine tune ourselves and tune ups
yeah tune-ups i can tell you after this
conversation i'm leaving with the
different mindsets
i'm very excited for people to hear this
episode and hopefully feel the same way
we absolutely love you and you guys love
you absolutely we'll love her follow her
at maria menounos on social media yeah
anything else better together podcast
with marie manuela the new netflix show
yes yes
by the way can i just say something
first of all kevin's like the toughest
critic ever but you guys are incredible
and i'll tell you why
because
not just because i mean first of all you
wrote a beautiful intro and kevin always
said to me
give someone the intro that they never
got and you did that oh thank you but
also your questions you listen
and you have very insightful um
like translations of things that people
take years to build to
um you come from very you know you come
from incredible parents who um i'm sure
had a role obviously in that too but um
yeah it's a good mixing job i'll tell
you this
when we
first had the idea of doing a podcast
and sophia and i were nervous we didn't
know if we were good interviewers good
listeners good responders
my mom said study maria's work and
that's what we did she said
yes before we even did anything we'd
listen to you and yeah
like the way you would talk with sl you
just everything you were like okay we
got to mimic everything she's doing
you've got it down yeah that's a huge
compliment no i mean it i'm not i don't
throw bouquets even if i love people i
don't throw bouquets and you guys were
just the way you process things and your
take on it
um was really really unique so
even though i wasn't grading you
i'll see you guys i wanted to stop in
the middle of it and tell you and then i
was like no i don't want to scare them
spare me any day
we'll see you guys next tuesday bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you